monsieur ministres vont soir bienvenue à
24 face en ce moment où il rentrait
entre espoir et inquiétude selon les
différents points de vue vous êtes
ministre vous êtes un ancien enseignant
que qu'est ce que vous ressentez
aujourd'hui l'espoir inquiétude à peu
des deux la fébrilité je vous dis la ggt
ce matin là sur le terrain avec les
élèves les enseignants les parents
tout le monde était très très content
mais il y avait quand même une petite
fébrilité
normal vu c'est une rentrée scolaire
différente des autres mais tout le monde
était content d'être le social c'est
très compliqué je vais aborder avec vous
d'abord les deux questions chaudes du
jour qui ont été soulevées dans
l'actualité
la première cette fameuse question du
sport études monsieur legault a été
interviewé là dessus on entendu
l'extrait tout à l'heure en début
d'émission le sport études
pourquoi pourquoi ne pas aller de
l'avant avec ça quand on sait tous que
ça représente pour les jeunes qui
adhèrent à ce programme d'abord il ya eu
du sport études à cuba a non c'est pas
vrai souffle quand tout à l'heure on
discutait avec directeur général du sens
du service scolaire de beauce etchemin
qui me confirmait que tous les
programmes de sport-études gymnastique
ok allez avoir lieu dans son centre de
service et ils ont tout simplement
appliquer les règles on a dit depuis la
mi juin
c'est pas de nouveautés que les élèves
doivent être dans des groupes classe
stable donc suffi que tous les élèves de
la même équipe soit dans la même classe
c'est pas si facile organisée d'un point
de vue logistique
donc c'est compliqué c'est faisable et
plusieurs plusieurs élèves vont
continuer de vivre leur passion et pour
les autres pour lesquels c'est pas
possible en ce moment parce que ça pose
trop de contraintes logistiques pour la
récolte et on va revoir tout seul dans
quelques semaines si on applique bien
les règles avec capable peut-être dans
des assouplissements même d'éclater les
groupes classe plus tard mais pour
l'instant
prudence prudence dans le même temps ces
jeunes rapporté des témoignages dans ce
sens y en a qui vont décrocher de leur
sport études pour aller dans la ligue
civile de leur patelin
ils vont pas jouer au hockey ou au
football dans leur patelin mai à l'école
y en aura pas est-ce qu est-ce que c'est
pas un exemple de confusion encore
et conseil qui doit être doivent être
respectés c'est pas une bonne idée là de
faire le tour des consignes des
directives savez si avec monsieur arruda
monsieur dubé dès le départ on était
clair pour dire écoutez pour limiter la
propagation entre les jeunes pas qu'il
ya d'explosion c'est important que les
élèves restent en groupe class côtoie
toujours à peu près les mêmes 20 25
élèves pour éviter qu'ils s'exposent
peut-être la contamination ou qui
contamine parce qu'il la trappe et le
donne à d'ordre ce fameux virus la
meilleure idée là c'est d'être prudent
on veut protéger nos élèves on veut
protéger notre père notre personnel
scolaire et dans ce cadre là c'est un
peu plus compliqué mais si possible
d'organiser des parascolaires et du
sport études jls est nommé à 100 200
scolaires qu'ils étaient arrivés
d'autres vont y arriver aussi
compromission on veut pas que ça arrive
on veut garder nos écoles ouvertes mais
dans quelle proportion ça va de l'avant
ça va pas de l'avant c'est la majorité
qui auront leur sport études ou
seminelli une minorité et le jeu je vois
qui est certain certaines directions des
codes certains parents nous disent où on
non l'europe
j'ai demandé une recension pour la
semaine prochaine autour du 1er
septembre l'entreprise 5 septembre le
temps que je reçoive toutes les
informations de savoir dans quelle
mesure les écoles ou les centres de
services réussi à organiser leurs
fonctions mais écoutez là on n'est pas
dans une rentrée normale on en découvre
visage on a les flèches au sol on a
moins d'élèves qu'en chaque autobus et
on a cette obligation de rester en
groupe stable pour éviter propager le
virus je pense que tout le monde est
d'accord pour dire qu'on doit être
prudent pour ne pas retourner des écoles
fermer des classes cham consensus ou
presque des gens qui est qui
contestaient conseil mais ce camp les
consignes sont claires
ça va quand on les comprend bien sans
qu'on les ait pas comprise au collège
français dans la région de montréal
et qu'on aurait renvoyé tout le monde à
l'école et ce à un prix cinq heures
avant d'avoir une réponse de la santé
publique alors qu'il ya des choses à
régler rapidement pour l'atlantique
c'est pas parfait au jour j je pense pas
que beaucoup de gens s'attendaient à ce
que ce soit parfait au jour 1 avec
l'immensité des défis auxquels on fait
face tous les acteurs du réseau scolaire
mais moi je le lève le chapeau aux
directions des cas aux casques aux
employés de soutien aux enseignants qui
se sont préparés pour accueillir les
élèves comme cindy j'étais sur le
terrain aujourd'hui je voyais des
sourires et des gens contents d'être là
c'est sûr que dans les premiers jours on
s'adapte on sait juste qu'on s'assure
d'avoir vraiment bien compris la
consigne tout le monde la même manière
il va y avoir des ajustements dans les
premiers jeux c'est normal autre dossier
chaud et ça touche la région de
sherbrooke monsieur le ministre
une de mes collègues afin reportages là
tu écoutais 1200 élèves privés de
transport scolaire à cause de la copie à
cause évidemment du nombre peut pas
imaginer que des enfants qui sont en
garde partagée perdre le fardeau sur les
parents le stress que ça 1200 élèves
on apprend sol aujourd'hui le jour de la
rentrée
quel et vous faire ce que c'est une
priorité pour leur donner le service est
une priorité de donner le maximum de
services bond s'explique les médias la
presse le jour de la rentrée mais je
pense que les parents savent et si
j'avais le transport ou pas avant
évidemment que l'autobus base de cinq
mille deux cents élèves contre un qui
nous vient de la santé publique mais
pour le bien-être des fruits des enfants
ont d'habitude dans une auto bus
scolaire on peut asseoir trois enfants
par ben la consigne maintenant pour
éviter la propagation ses deux enfants
par ben donc ses presque 30 à - l'a
rendu là on peut bien sûr mais davantage
autobus sur la route et je vous dis on
va aller dans cette direction là parce
que monsieur trudeau et l'argent
on dit depuis hier qui a la voix des
fonds du gouvernement fédéral qui allait
venir sans les utiliser une partie de
ces sables pour essayer de mettre
davantage de véhicules sur la route
quand on est capable d'embaucher des
chauffeurs pour améliorer ses services
aux familles donc c'est certain qu'on va
s'améliorer là dessus mais on peut pas
tout à coup à remplir les autobus et
propagé des mois pour se préparer pour
cette rentrée là moi je pense à tous ces
parents là tous ces enfants que parce
que c'est un gouvernement qui dit
prendre soin des parents des enfants
mais je pense à 1200 parents 2400
personnes de 1200 élèves donc de 1400
par personne fait près de 4000 personnes
qui vivent un stress parce qu'ils ont
plus de transport scolaire à ce qu est
une priorité
et justement vous évoquez l'argent du
fédéral j'ai su s'ouvrir ça c'est juste
sherbrooke là je suis écouté je suis
très sensible à ces situations là il se
fait pas plaisir quand les parents qui
avaient accès du transport scolaire l'an
passé n'ont pas cette année des fois ils
ont fait lorsque vous avez dit là ils
ont limité transports à l'adresse ou des
fois ils ont allongé la distance de
marche une enfant qui avait accès au
transport pour cent à partir d'un ou
deux kilomètres mais le savez 4 km une
plus grande distance de marche avant
d'avoir droit au transport scolaire à
cause des mesures et on doit on doit
vivre avec mais faut pas qu'elle ait le
dollar c'est ce qu'on fait en minimiser
les impacts et on voit on va travailler
avec les sens que service pour mettre
davantage de véhicules sur la route
rendez les familles espérons la passe
pour toi que la pandémie la pandémie
elle dollars ge pour non plus l excuse
n'a pas donné les services essentiels de
transport est un service essentiel parce
que pas nécessairement de transport en
commun dans le coin et les parents qui
font la conciliation famille-travail en
télétravail prenez la mesure du problème
c'est ce que je comprends pénurie
d'enseignants
vous dites que ça va on embauche les
syndicats disent public mais
l'enseignant en même temps recrute des
gens qui ont pas nécessairement toutes
les qualifications à ce moment ci il ya
beaucoup de vent lors du décrochage
toujours du décrochage côté des
enseignants
la situation est critique la situation
difficile depuis quelques années déjà
arnaud dans nos écoles pour recruter des
enseignants est en situation de pénurie
je l'avais bien dit l'an dernier quand
on constaté qu'il manquait à peu près
trois cent soixante enseignants au 1er
septembre
ce qu'on nous dit c'est que en date de
vendredi dernier au 21e
il ya manquer environ 256 à temps plein
il y en avait aussi qui nous manquait à
temps partiel donc ce que j'ai vu
c'était que grosso modo c'est un état
dans une meilleure posture que l'an
dernier où les embauches d'enseignants à
temps plein pour les temps partiels ça
semble plus difficile cette année
mais grosso modo chaque jour qui passe
on embauche des gens je sais que au
centre de sa vie scolaire de montréal il
me disait il ya quelques jours qui leur
manquait 500 dans cinq ans comprend tout
le monde temps plein temps partiel ce
matin nous dire mangochie 300 en
quelques jours et on continue de le
faire donc on peut pas minimiser ce a
ensuite occupé à lyon on y travaille on
y travaille
et ceci dit la situation s'améliore il
manquera pas mais l'enseignant alors que
les élections la sociale dans la
question ont-ils toutes les
qualifications normalement requise où on
accepte de baisser ses exigences là et
ça fait déjà un certain temps ce qu'ils
ont et brevets danser mais bien sûr ça
vaut bien plusieurs ou ce qu'on appelle
des rares d'enseignement c'est à dire
que il on se pose on un baccalauréat en
français ou en histoire devienne
enseignant secondaire et continue
ensuite les cours du soir pour faire une
maîtrise qualifiant en enseignement
pédagogique
donc je pense que ce sont des gens qui
vont vouloir faire carrière et qui
voient tout de faire accompagner nos
jeunes merci beaucoup se mêlaient bonne
basse et batterie